another new video of a mob drenching New
York's finest here the group armed with
pails of water target two female
officers this incident coming days after
earlier water ambushes in the city which
offers a lesson in human nature if other
people see they can get away with crimes
then others will do it too the lack of
response by the officers before offered
tacit encouragement it's only water true
but what's next
who knows but we know why the cops don't
respond these are the guardians of a
liberal and clave so other than the
hard-working taxpayers who would support
them not the leaders they protect any
arrests would draw protests of excessive
force and Al Sharpton would be out with
a sign before you can say to Juana
Brawley and if you don't know who she is
then you don't know al the mayor of New
York is more frightened of mean tweets
than he is of crime so we know where
City Hall will stand right under their
desks and the mayor embarking on an
already absurd presidential run will use
his son once again as an example of how
the NYPD racially profiles minorities
even though the force is largely made up
of minorities so this could get worse as
prisons closed detention of suspects
awaiting trial is eliminated from for
many in 2020 it's a lesson learned in
major cities achievements in law
enforcement over decades by competent
humans and principled politicians can
quickly erode once electus is in charge
you want to see your future try downtown
LA just watch where you step the police
are in a tight spot there there are
people that think they should be fired
if they don't respond but if you do your
job you risk becoming a public spectacle
because if you will if a mob forms
around you and you end up having to tase
somebody you're the bad guy absolutely I
mean they are in an untenable position
and you know you look at the spectrum of
human behavior I mean this is where
lawlessness ends up heading right there
are places in the world where the police
don't like to go in yeah because they're
not welcome there and if they do
something they may get attacked that is
just the the seed that we're seeing in
these moments and as as you said you
know it is so easy to trip over to the
other side of that these people get up
every morning they risk their lives
every day to protect the
in their communities and you know who's
gonna be less safe because of incidents
like this all of the people who live in
that community because also who want
home have to be police officers today
yeah you know I mean it's a very very
tough job and I give them an enormous
amount of credit but that these are
appalling appalling scenes for all
Americans
Jessica shouldn't mayor de Blasio just
call it a day come back and try to run
his city yeah absolutely I think we can
all agree on that one president Blasio
I'm sorry
use his formal title king of the
blackout yes you're the black out guys
that's trumpian he should absolutely
come home and run the city I think
they're probably about 12 to 15 people
who should go back to their very
important jobs and let us elect someone
who can beat Donald Trump in 2020 I this
is obviously terrible to see I grew up
here in New York City cops around all
the time
always have had a great relationship
with them and you know they do us a
great service and when it looks at the
data confidence in the police is
hovering around where it has been
actually the last five years but respect
for the police is actually on an upward
tick and they they credit that with the
protective measures that are being
implemented like more body cameras extra
scrutiny of Department so I think that
has to continue obviously taking this to
the more national conversation here I
think that when you have things like the
police officer who put Eric garner in a
chokehold and he walks free a couple
weeks ago those are the kinds of things
that then don't give people confidence
in the criminal justice system and in
the police force that then leads to not
necessarily the water Soaker stuff but
lack of confidence in the force well I
would agree that the respect is the
cornerstone if good police work but if
you let someone publicly disrespect you
like that and you don't do anything
about it that's just gonna make your job
more dangerous and the streets more
dangerous so I think they should have
acted this is like you know when when
men instead of punching another guy they
slap him in the face it's like the most
humiliating thing that you can do to
someone that's what this is like it's
almost more disrespectful to throw water
on a cop and
is to resist arrest but that's what
these guys want they want to be seen in
the streets as being disrespectful
because for some reason they think that
helps their street cred and so what if
they get arrested it's you know that's
like a badge of honor they come out in a
few hours they can tell everybody they
become legends that's how stupid this
whole thing is and this does have root
causes though they had Colin Kaepernick
everyone's hero you know wearing socks
that had police's pigs they had Bill
DeBlasio saying his own son should be
careful when he's around
I don't police officers and then you had
black lives matter chanting you know fry
him up like bacon talking about that and
CNN went on a hold jihad against police
department on the second Obama term that
wasn't very smart New York City police
officers turned their back on the mayor
of the city when he walked by them it's
not fair to blame these kinds of things
on Colin Kaepernick was somewhere
Kennedy just want to put imagine it
those are to wait those are two women
surrounded by I think a majority of men
if they weren't police officers this
would be actually as yeah well if it
isn't but somehow it's not making the
news the the mayor has to come out
pretty forcefully and say how the police
are going to respond and defend
themselves and there is a con there is a
conversation to be had in this country
about criminal justice reform but the
people who are on the street with
buckets dousing cops they're not the
ones who are leading the charge and they
actually do the entire movement a great
disservice and it's incredibly
unfortunate for those of us who have
family members who've been in law
enforcement it's the last thing you want
to see because the worry is what does
this escalate ooh
and to your point I just did a walking
tour of Skid Row in Los Angeles
absolutely putrid disgusting sad the way
the city government is forcing human
beings to lose weigh and in Portland
with members of antiphon quick-dry
cement among people disguised as
milkshakes and cops are told to stand
down they're not allowed to do anything
and you know really lost perspective